boa noite dia primeiramente agradecer aí
ao certo de que os professores da da
vaga e também por não aceitarem me
convidarem para estar presente hoje pede
que já foi um alvo de muita inspiração
pra mim de vídeo na internet já que a
pista é muito prazeroso pra mim poder
estar aqui hoje
convidado para falar sobre o diabetes é
um projeto que objetiva onde o 1
a arte que eu faço que é o grafite ao
street haiti com a questão do lixo que e
da coleta seletiva
só que antes de falar sobre chat e tudo
mais e eu não queria falar sobre uma uma
idéia é o uma motivação maior que é o
que motivou mesmo orixás que tudo mais o
próprio grafite ea ilustração desde que
a questão do twitter self é o faça você
mesmo
então é um papel que que ganhou bastante
força na década de 50
depois ganhou mais força ainda com o
punk e hip hop com uma confecção e
também com a criação de locais para
fazer os passos de dança espaço dá pra
fazer a arte para fazer um espaço com
música e tudo fazendo por conta dessas
coisas me excluído deles serem culturas
pomares finalizadas elas não têm tanto
ou incentivo privado
o uso de ordem que esse gás da entidade
delas mesmo pra se fazer acontecer é um
que eu vejo adolescentes são coisas que
eu consegui mais essas duas dessas duas
culturas assim constitui dos céus é uma
coisa que que veio muito presente assim
a minha caminhada sempre essa
curiosidade de fazer por conta e é mais
presente ainda mesmo tudo pela questão é
mais presente ainda pela questão do fim
de uma de uma cidade grande sinal de que
tinha já conseguido de grafite no
interior de são paulo porque é bom
bonito
a cidadezinha pequena 40 mil habitantes
e lá então tinha nada disso é a minha
o meu contato com isso era quando ia
para são paulo eo mw e que as pichações
e achava muito legal pra gente e eu
ficava pensando no nosso conjunto está
fazendo aquilo que hora que eles fazem
porque eles fazem como eles fazem
indicavam conteúdo cabeça em com 11
pontos o que é feito isso e quando
chegava em casa e ia buscar um caderno
mesmo nas carteiras e sempre com essa
estética onde é que eu ficava muito na
minha cabeça
das letras dos estilos desenho mesmo
então trazer muito sempre gostei de
desenhar desde pequeno é muito só que o
software tem um contato depois com
grafite mesmo depois que eu me formei em
principal do fla em guarapuava que eu
estava trabalhando já uma agência mas
estava insatisfeito com o trabalho e vão
tentar desenhar mais e tentar não vai
tentar
empreender é assunto só não vamos fazer
por conta
então comprei algumas tintas látex 163
la em uma aparente que tinha e e comecei
a pintar ficou muito ruim do óbvio e
depois fiz em outros 45 em cada um
eu ia aprendendo alguma coisa que pude
correr muita tinta o nosso aqui estou
fazendo errado sem que ela não conseguia
fazer acordo é sempre uma evolução e
depois que eu fui a curitiba
eu me mudei de curitiba daí eu vi já
tinha uma cena de grafite em tinga então
já tinha os personagens que já tinha
história lá é uma cena que já tinha
começado há muito tempo então foi muito
legal ver que eles chegarem e ver que
aquilo acontecia de uma forma muito mais
orgânica
só que eu não tinha esse contato com as
pessoas então não só chega em curitiba
estava assinado assim como quando era
criança eu chegava são paulo estava
fascinado com as pichações grafite não
com uma em curitiba mesmo quando eu
mudei pra lá eu conheci muita gente né
uma coisa que acontece muito intuitivo
gente viu o carro do pai
muita gente faz isso e um dia que a
gente foi lá foi acabando assim as
pessoas foram embora e eu que ficava sol
é poeta delas que era um lixo né então
nasciam com as bebidas que op isso eles
deixaram aqui no bairro e como os amigos
aí a loucura de forma nenhuma
um leva esse lixo fora parte todo mundo
aqui mas ficar todo sujo e só que a
gente percebeu também que não é só uma
questão das pessoas que é ao mundial um
elevado risco elas deixavam gostavam mas
além disso não tinha tino ou no local e
então tinha se a essa falta de estrutura
também e aí a gente começou a debater
como que dava pra se resolver aquilo que
eu pensei boa seria nossa espécie uma
lixeira sem que elas fossem resultado
até dar uma visibilidade para elas né
as pessoas estão simplesmente ver que
não tem uma cheia mas mas sim tem uma
arte além da lixeira
então há uma forma de atenção sobre isso
até ontem um projeto um pandeiro com um
[Música]
pé e um pequeno botão e porque foi uma
coisa bem massa também porque é como eu
tinha chegado em curitiba
os juros só que estava começando a
aprender alguma coisa
e foi bem legal
primeiro eu conheci um cara que eu tinha
um amigo que conheci um cara sincero
velho é um botão eu abriu a tampa de um
formão em pnl é mulher detonou a bomba e
lá mesmo e foi de longe observando
depois como reação do
aí é que foi bem legal ver aqui que as
pessoas já começaram a circular em mg ba
onde ficava todo mundo e embora não
tenha outro dia de manhã garis já a
recolha dos lixos e aproveitei conversei
com ele e assim farei outro como o que
achou
ele falou que tinha melhorado bastante
porque tinha dado parte inteira para
recolher o lixo de uma pequena nação
assim ele só quebrou um tabu pode ajudar
o cara e manter é mais livre
então é aquele que é um monstrinho
acertar com mendonça os políticos que
ele é um vizinho em uma esquina em tom
marrom tem bastante base em curitiba
trajando a isso há um dia eu passei três
dias não estava mais
num todo não sei se ele perguntar ao
descobrir que o pai
ele cuidou bem legal ver isso que eu
tinha pintado e chamar todo mundo e
depois ele saiu
para a aluna sombria que agora eu não
sabia o paradeiro dele
esse outro tiro ou cadeirinha e daí é um
eu fizer é um catador de lixo e é um
personagem que usava bastante na época
que era a questão das máscaras de
caveira a carreira ela representa mesmo
que a unidade de todos nós todos nós
somos iguais na carreira então
representa a igualdade do do catador de
latinha mesmo essa questão da
invisibilidade perder e na própria
sociedade né
as pessoas passam por cima não mora no
entorno tinha pra ele que ele tá nem
trabalhando dessa forma esses foram os
três primeiros que eu fiz não aprovada
mesmo e eu sozinho é muito boa que acaba
gritando que tinha um amigo que tinha
lugar para se prontificar a lavar piauí
e sempre vai acontecendo isso se você
encontrar gente boa no caminho de uma
forma e vai crescendo em uma dessas
idéias
imagine uma copa que eles estavam sem
cinto é o pessoal de são paulo estava
reunindo o projetos antes da copa
angel jones no brasil ele estivesse
fazendo algumas coisas e e selecionar o
projeto foi bem legal e foram para
curitiba travaram e conversaram com a
gente e isso foi um catalisador é muito
legal assim de muita gente fazendo coisa
eu acabei conhecendo mais os projetos
através de isso aí várias pessoas acabam
conhecendo também bichat entrando em
contato porque queriam somar os projetos
e as idéias
então é muito legal porque eu só
consegui fazer o que eu queria é que é a
arte a trafti street age a ilustração e
projetos sociais de várias coisas que os
projetos foi em projetos que o azul que
é uma cidade do interior do paraná que
eles os moradores tinham uma deficiência
muito grande todo o bairro tinha uma
deficiência grande de coleta de lixo do
bairro
então eles foram atrás de de construir
umas caixas coletoras e por conta mesmo
sem sem intenção nenhuma de jones nos
tudo inclusive a própria comunidade foi
construído eo exemplo já contava comigo
pra ele ministrará uma oficina de
grafite com os alunos e professores e
artistas locais e foi muito legal muito
prazeroso fazer isso assim que foram
três dias de pintura foram 11 caixas
pintadas e foi muito gratificante e é
como é e se fazendo parte assim eles
conseguem conceber muito melhor assim é
quando a pessoa faz parte ela cuida
muito mais depois então deu tão certo
que no outro ano a gente foi de ouro fez
mais seis caixas e eu o convidei os
artistas têm amigos
curitiba também pra pintar em primeiro
lugar que a gente foi ver as caixas que
tenham sido feitas no ano passado e elas
a 1
muitos impactos em tal novas e um estava
funcionando muito melhor
outra coisa que aconteceu de potência os
projetos que a gente vai encontrando o
caminho hoje apagou se ressignificando e
sair um pouco dessa questão da coleta de
lixo e entramos numa questão da coleta
de livros assim que amanhece pasta da
cultura para que esse projeto é oferecer
o livro que é do mais amigas lá de
curitiba
angela em que elas pegam nos deixou
deixa 11 pontos de arrecadação de livros
em vários lugares em bares ea escolas e
depois de se mudar pra mim essa troca
dos livros que você já leu
você pega outro se você não leu e vai
fazer essa troca
então eu me contratar para pintar os
latões para servirem de pontos de apoio
[Música]
para atrair mais essa galera mesmo que
faça união mesmo do a intenção é que a
dose livro como os personagens ali são
projetos que que agora a gente está até
no projeto uma potência em curitiba onde
a gente vai trabalhar porque estão
trabalhando na pintura e eu vou
trabalhar também a copa grafite como
eles
hoje eu já fiz empresa
tenho vários estados já que o que eu
acho mais querido é uma se e que cada um
é uma identidade
cada um tem porque eu estava em um
conceito cada um tem um significado
mesmo e isso que eu acho legal essa arte
é tudo ter sido esse conceito tem um
porquê não só pela estética mesmo e é
aqui que tudo começou em uma coisa o
lixo e importante é essa mensagem que
você acredita na idéia assim não espere
critical momento e bilhante tudo se
alinha aos corpos se alinharem para
fazer vai fazer não só entre a gente
[Música]
[Aplausos]